this has been an incredible award season
for you and an incredible time and I
think even Olivia mention it when she
was up on stage tonight that she wished
it would have gone a different way for
you how are you feeling I'm feeling
really really good darling of this award
season I was upset about all the people
who bet that I was going to hold it all
the people in Jersey tell me about your
luck this fashion is insane wonderful
it's of course it's our money what time
you think you'll get into bed tonight
Glen oh I don't know probably not
terribly late but six have scrambled
eggs if you could sum up this ride with
this film and what it's meant to you
it's the last time we're going to talk
about it you know what has this meant to
you to be recognized for this entire
thing this meant that most of me is all
the the love that I've felt it has meant
it is moved me it's overwhelmed me
actually and to me that's it more women
won Oscars tonight than have ever won
Oscars in an Oscar history and I think
that's a cool thing redoble that is a
very cool thing and it's going to just
continue
[Music]